hey guys this is going to be a slightly
different video than what you're used to
I promised the markiplier sings badly
channel who is not me by the way there
was some confusion about that I promised
him that I would react to their newest
music video that they made just for me
in celebration of 6 million subscribers
since I didn't do it
for 5 million so I'm here I'm just about
to watch the video with you guys and I'm
ready to be inundated with emotions so
here we go you should be seeing this
just about the right time has been said
and I know the song cuz I started it and
I know
[Music]
chin up
I can't step into the spotlight
[Music]
I just
soundtrack
[Music]
when this world is
asked you to
until the stars of
[Music]
all right
I don't want to say anything cuz I don't
know what's going on right now oh yeah
this from the dude the moon soundtrack
in its cover
[Music]
oasis
I feel
they're just not sure if speech we mem
[Music]
yeah
I should do when this world is
[Music]
asked you to
until the stars are
you see
[Music]
I knew I was W feel big baby kiss
before I started recording I've heard
like the first
[Music]
I heard the first word that I just
couldn't I knew that I wasn't gonna be
I'm not sad I'm not sad that's not it
this is that
it's a said things like this put things
in perspective for me for how how many
people are really out there and that's
what I always try to remember is I
always try to I always try to think that
there are literally six billion people
behind the screen here in that are
watching my videos and there are
literally there have many people that
can be organized in doing one thing and
thank you to everyone that participated
in this and take you for market price
things badly for making it organizing it
oh man I didn't mean to cry like a baby
in front of you guys I think a lot we
have sickened a lot this past weekend
when I was trying to think of what I was
gonna say for the 6 million video that I
did you know I didn't want it to be a
sad video like I've done before and I
didn't want it to be just me blubbering
into a camera again with I was thinking
about my trip to the White House and I
was in Washington DC and I I went around
and I saw the monuments and the
memorials in had I saw the entire time I
was there I couldn't help but think oh
there's only one person in the world
that would have wanted to see me there
and and and I couldn't stop thinking
about how how proud my dad would have
been of me to be there and invite it
down to the White House because he was
like the biggest Patriot anyone could
have ever been he was a 24-year military
man and you know he never really agreed
with what the government was doing and
what any one point but he believed it
you know he believed in America he was
very into that before that became a joke
that really meant something to him he
was seeing all these people here's
[Music]
it's it's not like it makes me sad it
doesn't make me sad that I see but the
fact that so many people can be
organized and people work so hard to
make these things that they do and you
guys can check out the video for
yourself is a link in the description
blah I know you guys just saw it here
and you know I hate to take away views
from their video but because I made a
reaction video too and I'm obviously
showing it to you guys here but just I
just wanted to say thank you guys so
much for being with me on this journey
[Music]
I've only really done to react thing
like this once before him it's uh who's
heard the twenty thousand subscriber
video that people made for me oh I'm so
sorry for blubbering like an idiot and
it may not seem like there's a good
reason to watching that for some people
out there they don't understand but I
feel a connection to people every every
time I meet someone who's a fan of mine
and says that I inspired them to do
something that's what makes me more
proud of my decision of what I'm doing
in my life it got him I'm not ah I gotta
manly things gods explosions oh all I
can say is now all I can say is thank
you guys I can only say that over and
over and over again thank you guys for
believing in me and thank you guys for
being here for me and thank you guys for
letting me have the chance to live this
life I'm glad that you guys put your
trust in me and I don't ever want to
betray that trust so I spoke with my
family too about the DC trip and a lot
of people from my small town are talking
about me and it's interesting
that's about all I could say it's
interesting cuz I can't compare to
anything else I've ever done in my life
and I know that things are just gonna
get weirder and weirder and weirder and
I loved every second of it for as long
as I have you know I loved every second
of it so thank you guys so much for
watching thank you so much for suffering
through this with me if this was an
ordeal for you uh-huh it was an ordeal
for me too but just thank you guys so
much I'm always always going to be
grateful for what you guys
I've done for me and what you guys have
allowed me to do so one last time thank
you and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye